while the test positivity holds steady
the testing demand appears to be
dwindling 8 news now crews checked out
three local sites between 9 this morning
and 11 to find barely any vehicles
madison kimbrough joins us live at one
of those sites madison did the lack of
lines show us testing is slowing
well you know workers believe so if you
take a look behind me you'll see that
really nothing is going on we've seen
maybe 10 cars within the couple hours
that we've been here a big difference
from weeks prior where they had to shut
down the testing site due to the massive
number of cars waiting in line
according to the health district and
nevada department of health and human
services the daily case counts are still
high but the massive surge in testing
this week has slowed hayden michaels
administers these tests here at the
heinrich ymca he confirms the noticeable
decline in people coming to test
even last week it was more busy than
this week
so i don't know i guess the numbers just
fluctuated with people not want to get
tested here or going somewhere else you
know personally i think it's just you
know the holiday season everybody was
out and now everybody was jamming to get
their tests in to go back home and
traveling and now i guess it's finally
starting to die down this is video from
centennial hills ymca no cars when we
arrived around 10 today then around 10
30 at the skyview ymca in north las
vegas about four vehicles both of these
locations are closed for the day and
will reopen saturday at eight in the
morning
and this location is open until six
tonight and will be open through on to
the weekend from eight to four now as
for other locations offering testing we
want to know if their lines at the
locations that you have been to if so
let us know through twitter my handle is
below at matt kimbrough i want to be
able to see that message and we can
incorporate that in the 5 pm reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now
madison